nouveau numéro de reporter le dock le
magazine de reportages long format de
france 24 direction le sénégal pour
revenir sur un massacre coloniale
longtemps étouffée à l'aube du 1er
décembre 1944 dans le camp militaire tia
roj dans la banlieue de dakar des
tirailleurs ouest africains sont
assassinés par leurs frères d'armes
français avec qui il avait combattu les
nazis il venait d'être rapatriés
pourquoi combien ont été tués ou sont
ils enterré près de 80 ans après les
versions divergent et les zones d'ombré
demeurent une histoire méconnue que la
jeune génération essaye de faire
reconnaître dans ce document réalisé en
coproduction avec public sénat nous
allons suivre maggie babacar et aïcha
trois jeunes artistes chacun dans leur
cheminement artistique qu'il cherche à
explorer la mémoire de ce drame thiaroye
44 un film écrit et réalisé par marie
thomas pénet et françois-xavier des
stores
[Musique]
actuellement on est dans le tarn
mais là où logeait n'était la visite
éclair jeudi
par endroits
avec les
infrastructures on a créé des hôpitaux
des écoles des routes on a toi levée
voilà
j'ai moi j'aurais vraiment aimé parfois
juste à dire ici ou au milieu de terrain
qui prendra pour le soir la nuit de près
d'un tiers vide entre leur vie pour quoi
faire mais tard devait être un lieu de
pèlerinage voilà et chaque année les
gens viennent piscine voilà visite
vraiment nos grands pères pour les
intérêts mais où exactement chut c'est
ça votre époux et
entra au securities transfert mais où
exactement qui nous dit que kate qui
nous dit on n'est pas en train de
marcher sur ces sources actuellement on
ne sait pas
actuellement où les gens lorsqu'ils
étaient en train de construire n'ont pas
boudé
le lieu exact où les hivers on était un
territoire
[Musique]
les
contrôles
[Musique]
m
c
[Musique]
g
ces lieux qui avait pas mal ça je le
savais mais paris publié par
voie là je savais qu'il ne pensait même
pas qu'ils allaient devenir militaire ou
bien quelqu'un qui allait à la guerre
après ça dépend des périodes il ya eu
des périodes où les amis recevez bongo
montrez nous voilà
informés surtout au début en fait
surtout au début était le seul candidat
ya des gens qui disent que le mobile est
devenu de la vivent ailleurs mais
inflige dans le désert à le blizzard
mais
voilà il faut tirer sur l'ailé les
allemands ailleurs
nous sommes animés
[Musique]
a dakar l'entraînement des troupes
noires se poursuite avec méthode
il est émouvant de lire sur le visage de
ses hommes le même cas mais la même
résolution qui animait déjà leurs aînés
lorieux combattants de 1914
et c'est en portant leurs barbes 1 à la
mode du pays que les nouvelles troupes
gagne les navires qui les transporteront
en france où courageusement ils
rempliront leurs devoirs aux côtés de
trout métropolitaine
[Musique]
animé du plus bel esprit de sacrifice
les hommes de nos colonies ont répondu
d'un élan unanime à l'appel de la mère
patrie
[Musique]
salomon con
je m'appelle aïcha j'ai passé une grande
partie de mon enfance à chamouille
et j'ai écrit une pièce de théâtre
autour de l'histoire du massacre de
thiaroye
je suis déjà très très honoré d'être
présente aujourd'hui
et de pouvoir vous écouter
alors moi c'est m'a dit je suis artiste
et chanteuse rappeuse
activistes en même temps notamment un
taux de babacar your
docteur égale n'est calé ce comédien au
cinéma
aussi
contre le laxisme et légumes
je suis le plus dingue absolue ans qui a
été
élue tout commence à kavala
du massacre est paru le 1er décembre
1940 à l'appel de sud qui sera parce que
le jour des funérailles les gens sont
venus dans la maison de demander à la
grammaire fadlallah mamadou goïta
mais grave qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est un pas qui n'est
pas à la baisse à cette époque-là
conducteur au cm2
quand le chien de guerre militaire est
sorti je me suis pas juste que vous
fassiez sadaoui
commentaire
plein de 1100 hectares
ça
est-ce que annoncé mais sa part
pour trouver quoi que
l'on ne connaît pas ce que le mot
dans
les médias
locaux les
valises
mon patron m'a mis des falaises pour
nous neyret
après un moment pas trop volontaire port
d'hambourg signé
abolir
les anciennes n'étaient pas volonté de
rien du tout les importateurs ne se
porte volontaire pour aller faire la
guerre
alors les envolées de force sont portés
au secours de la france et la france a
oublié 140 cas mais les yankees ont fait
le franc qui sont revenus et a demandé
son nom 41 poussière de notre île est
vous les massacrer comme ça parce qu'ils
ont osé demander comme cela
alors que ceux des français qui
aujourd'hui est ce que vous faites
quelque chose le 1er décembre chaque 1er
décembre chaque mois de ramadhan s'ils
ne savent pas pris part à dakar je passe
là bas pour
vous que je ne sais pas
où
exactement on le sait les a comptés
ils fabien causeur et charles bien là se
trouve quelque part ils ne veulent pas
dire la vérité
c'est bon ça danse et voilà il est là
votre disposition poser les questions et
tu pourras donner sa contribution en
fait ce cimetière militaire il a été
construit au moment de la première
guerre au début du 20e siècle pour na le
camp militaire qui a à peu près 1 km 1
kilomètre 5 qui est le plus grand camp
militaire en afrique de l'ouest où tous
les tirailleurs qui venait du soudan
français donc l'actuel mali du burkina
faso de la guinée etc étaient réunis au
sénégal c'est à partir de là c'est à
partir du pont de charolles puis de
dakar qu'ils ont marqué qu'ils ont
embarqué pour la france pendant la
première guerre mondiale et pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale il ya à peu près
200 milles africains qui sont réunis en
france qui vont être défait avec l'armée
française en 1940 et les tirailleurs
pourra retrouver à thiaroye plus tard
sont des tirailleurs qui ont été
prisonnier de guerre pendant quatre ans
de l'automne 1940 à l'automne 1944
combien ces délais
surtout des les gagner on parle en fait
du rappel de soldes de captivité malgré
le fait qu'ils aient été prisonnier
entre 40 et 44 il avait une solde chaque
jour qui sont notés sur des carnets et
c'est cette somme qui voilà qui au
moment de leur démobilisation devait
leur être versée qui n'a pas été versée
c'est tuer pour qu'ils arrêtent de
demander l'argent
ce qui est toujours compliqué en fait en
histoire c'est que on est obligé de
travailler à partir des sources qu'on a
hélas les sources qu'on a c'est les
documents de ceux qui les ont tués
l'armée française va considérer qu'il ya
eu une mutinerie et donc que c'est de la
faute des tirailleurs enfin elle va
considérer elle va désigner des rebelles
des mutins comme elle les appelle et
elle va prendre comme ça 48 tirailleurs
qu'elle va juger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les événements qui ont eu lieu ici en
décembre 1944 sont tout simplement
épouvantable
insupportable
et la france se grandit chaque fois
qu'elle est capable de porter un regard
lucide sur son passé et la france n'est
pas elle même quand elle détourne son
regard sur des événements qui ont pu à
un moment
assombrir son image
je voulais réparer une injustice
et salué la mémoire d' homme
qui portait l'uniforme français
et sur lesquels les français avaient
retourné leur fusil
car c'est ce qui s'est produit
ce fut la répression sanglante de pia
boys
alors françois hollande dans son
discours un emploi le mot
l'expression de répression sanglante
il me semble que c'est pas le
qualificatif le plus juste un employé
pour ce qui s'est passé faut quand même
bon faut quand même aussi reconnaître
quand même peut-être hollande d'avoir eu
ce discours d'avoir fait ce geste là et
quand il dit répression sanglante c'est
une façon de dire que finalement on les
a réprimés mais c'est parce que eux
avaient fait quelque chose qui voilà
peut-être que la réédification est
excessive elle est sûrement excessive
mais il pleut on peut la comprendre
moi je pense que l'eau thermale et pas
juste pour parler de ce que moi
j'appelle à un crime de masse après on
n'est pas dans un acte qui m'attend en
même temps on est dans une période de
guerre donc est ce qu'on peut dire que
c'est un crime de guerre voilà je pense
que c'est des questions qui sont
bon voilà deux lors du questionnement
historique s'est employé ces mots serré
chocobo par rapport aux africains
surtout quand on dit qu'on a fait un
crédit de ma sur vos ancêtres là ça va
ça aurait réveillé quelque chose au
niveau des jeunes c'est assez étonnant
comment ils changent en fait là il
tourne en fait il fait un exposé de
retournement de situation tout à fait il
dit pas et d'ipad mutinerie il dit pas
qui se sont ils emploient pas trop ce
terme indiquent ils ont été accusés deux
mais quelque part ils utilisent des
offices des effets mission pour le dire
quoi il remercie la faute alors de
manière assez subtil mais voilà les
identifie passer des butins il dit
finalement c'est assez compréhensible
ils se sont
se sont rassemblées ce qui est vraiment
faut en fait factuellement ils se sont
pas rassembler on les a rassemblés et où
l'a exécuté
[Musique]
ciao
bello
turiddu dans steam et demi il faut
attendre
la
femme à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fois
[Musique]
hier ses hommes ses hommes se sont
battus pour ta liberté ses hommes fait
rare monedan déjà payé ses hommes
réclament leur dû avant le camp de wc
sommes des tirailleurs mach mans
exterminer son défense des armées au
service de la mer français assassiné
mitraillé pu enterrer dans des fosses et
trois par trois cas par cas vous les
avait enterrés puis vous montez un vison
que qu'ils se sauveront des nez c'est un
contre l'humanité tous les jeux pour
enfants à toulouse samedi
comme ça
[Musique]
jarod eu des passes tu m'as trappe dans
ma tête tu raisonnes ta revendications
dépassent tu pour la résistance qui
avait tu dépasses du maghreb dans ma
tête je raisonne ta revendications des
battues par la résistance
[Musique]
je vais juste arranger la fin et c'est à
partir d'ici ici c'est un crime contre
l'humanité comme ce pas là aujourd'hui
moi j'ai même retrouvé dimanche à midi
ne se limite pas à la reconnaissance
comme la retenue et managers d'honneur
françois hollande ps
doudou diallo c'est un sénégalais il est
né en 1918 il a 26 ans et quelqu'un qui
est comme la plupart masqués dans la
vingtaine qui était assez jeune
s'il a été tué de diallo non non non oui
il n'est pas au camp le 30 novembre un
il est chez sa soeur à dakar hélas ce
1er décembre il revient il se fait
arrêter on va considérer que c'est un
meneur de la rébellion entre guillemets
alors qu'en fait il n'était pas là il
n'était pas là la veille
[Musique]
il a été embarqué en france à partir de
1940 il a d'abord été fait prisonnier
dans les vosges et puis après il est
fait prisonnier au camp de la marne à
rennes et d'ailleurs il est avec map
senghor à ce moment là ils sont
prisonniers en suisse car des plus
grands camps de prisonniers coloniaux à
ce moment là
c'est que l'allemagne voulait pas de
noirs sur le sol allemand carrément
parce qu'ils ont peur de maladies ils
ont peurs de contamination les ampleurs
de contact avec la population allemande
il ya quand même une vie dans les camps
ils travaillent ils ont des colis comme
ça de la croix rouge qui essaye un peu
de les soutenir et il ya des histoires
humaines qui se fait
notamment là on a 12 diallo sur cette
photo
avec d'une petite fille qui s'appelle
maïté
qu'il a eu en fait avec une marraine de
guerre je présume donc qui travaillent
dans le camp de prisonniers il travaille
pour les allemands à partir de 44 il va
se mettre à aider des réseaux de
résistants à l'extérieur du camp
il ya aussi beaucoup de tirailleurs dans
ces camps qu'ils vont réussir à s'évader
et qui vont soit intégrée des maquis un
peu plus tard soit s'est refait un
réseau de résistance qui ont participé à
la lutte contre l'occupant allemand en
france à ce moment-là
à l'automne 1944 les prisonniers de
guerre qui sont dispersés un peu partout
sur le territoire français ont commencé
à être réunies pour être rapatriés et il
ya une circulaire administrative qui a
été édicté un petit peu avant et qui dit
que le paiement doit être liquidée mais
un quart à l'embarquement à morlaix en
bretagne et les trois quarts en afrique
au débarquement toujours est il qu'ils à
certains tirailleurs qui vont pas croire
ce qu'ils vont pas croire ses promesses
qu'ils vont recommencer à réclamer leur
argent à ce moment-là tout l'argent qui
leur est dû et qui vont pas croire qu'on
va leur donner une fois débarqué à dakar
et qui n'ont pas embarqué ya à peu près
3 115 tirailleurs qui refusent
d'embarquer tête et que c'était juste
une promesse pour les voir les guerres
pire de leur territoire
[Musique]
touba bennama
wang yubo ghana au
kenya
du mali la
centrale
c'est ainsi qu'un hameau à new york
ban you know la
boulaye or ce day 2
amoul hollande l'homme eye-fi est
le double du manoir
raymond
gasc mossoul
prime as a man down
and may samarraï
axa met en dehors
les dom à la kabbale
de malak au bal
demain la coban
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dakar grandement français plaque
tournante de l'atlantique sud clés de la
route du caf ce port que l'angleterre
voulait s'approprier a été défendu
victorieusement par noman aux aviateurs
et nos soldats
au centre de ce jardin la place 3t avec
le monument aux morts de la guerre 1914
et voici le palais du gouverneur général
de l'ars wef c'est de là qu'est partie
l'endroit de résistance c'est là que fut
conçu la réponse cinglante à l'ultimatum
britannique à une fenêtre de ce palais
voici le gouverneur général - en
contemplant la ville qu'il a su
conserver à la france
dans cette école indigènes les petits
noirs continueront à étudier le français
protéger parce qu'ils ont su les
défenses ils l'apprendront chaque jour à
mieux connaître la france nouvelle
et celui qui en est le chef
on avait un régime qui était très
vigilants à dakar en 1940 la plupart des
officiers et des officiers généraux
collabore avec le gouvernement allemand
d'occupation - et effectivement c'est le
cas aussi des trajectoires des officiers
qu'on va retrouver à tiarei 144 les
tirailleurs coloniaux les soldats
africains c'est pas dans leurs priorités
ou le mans ils sont alors stéréotypes
coloniaux et puis
on leur dira mais eux ont été aussi des
planques et les officiers français
présents à dakar c'est quelque part des
planqués par rapport aux soldats
africains de cette époque
le 27 novembre 1944 il y à un premier
envoi de tirailleurs qui doit partir à
destination de bamako est en fait la
lega où nous refuser de monter ce qui va
occasionner la visite le lendemain
général dagnan qui gère la zone sénégal
mauritanie il a expliqué que les
tirailleurs était un peu un contrôle à
vous il va dire qu'il a failli être pris
en otage
laquelle lien qui ça c'est une manière
de dire en fait le détachement était en
état de rébellion de mutineries et c est
donc j'ai été contraints de mobiliser
une force de répression
et il va sortir cet ordre numéro un qui
est ici il nous dit des mesures sont
prises en vue de rétablir l'ordre dans
ce détachement tout en évitant dans la
mesure du possible ça c'est important
dans la mesure du possible il se manière
de se couvrir de faire usage des armes
fini ce passage par dia il s'agit je
cite de coiffer rapidement et par
surprise le camp de thiaroye en vue
d'empêcher tout de suite des tirailleurs
en lui dû remettre en ordre le
détachement et de manifester une telle
supériorité que les mutuelles puissent
mieux résisté que la sphère s'effectue
sans caisse coiffer coiffer voilà
rapidement quoi faire rapidement et par
surprise sa le clairement dire qu'il y
aura plus d espace à la discussion à la
négociation à quoi que ce soit il s'agit
de les encercler de faire aussi que la
sphère s'effectue l affaire entre
guillemets dans un espace clos quoi que
personne voilà le sois témoin de sa mère
que je comprends pas là si l'argent est
à dakar leur argent tous tout ce qu'on
la france leur doit
juste pourquoi simplement il leur donne
pas je ne comprends pas où est le
problème en fait qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait de cet argent
il est passé où après cet argent
sa personne le comprendre
il est où le problème ils réclament
leurs droits ils réclament leur argent
l'argent est là pourquoi il leur donne
pas tout simplement ça beaucoup de gens
ont dit dès l'époque il n'y avait pas
besoin de monter cette opération de
répression il suffisait de payer les
tirailleurs l'argent était là se
suffisait de leur régler ce qu'on leur
devait effectivement c'est un truc de
vouloir s'en débarrasser le plus vite
possible c'est peut-être un détournement
de fonds ça se voit là une hypothèse
aussi qui est très plausible sur lequel
moi je peux pas le confirmer
mais en tout cas supposés de travail et
et toujours est il que bon ça se passe
comme ça
on n'est pas sûr du petit équipement
quand on est vraiment sur des armes de
guerre mais est-ce qu'il est charles
hallé blanc il ya les chars avec les
sionistes qu'on voit dans les films en
guerre il ya les automitrailleuses et
après love tracks et des autos aussi on
a installé des mitrailleuses un dessus
en tout cas on sent que c'est pas très
bon et qui sont pas dans une démarche de
discuter de comment calmer la situation
que c'est vraiment il s'agit de lost
ratio de force mais ce qui ce qui est
clair
une chose qui se prépare et voilà
en fait et parler avec de langage codé
il faut que la faire ce pas son cas mais
quoi
[Musique]
le 30 novembre on a ce télégramme qui
vient de dakar qui de manière en fait de
mettre de mettre paris devant le fait
accompli on
nous dit je prends disposition pour
empêcher au besoin par la force
aggravation du mouvement et rétablir
autorités et prestige
iata et de réponse de paris l'a en tout
cas elles sont pas disponibles moi je ne
sais pas si c'est des choses qui ont été
enlevés des archives voilà le fait que
ça arrive là bas une heure du matin et l
opération commencent à 5 heures du matin
le jour même il se dit que dans les
bureaux à paris peut-être qu'ils
devraient être
n'a pas de rien dans ce cas pourquoi
j'entends beaucoup sur cette histoire-là
de gaulle était au courant
c'est vrai que c'est une interrogation
que je me suis que beaucoup d'historiens
se pose est ce que de gaulle a donné ça
aurait du sens si nous sommes donc ce
qui est certain c'est que de gaulle a
rien fait par rapport aux tirailleurs
qui était emprisonné après et toute la
suite va montrer qu'il s'agit
effectivement de maintenir les colonies
sous le giron des autorités françaises 1
et à n'importe quel prix en fait un et
au prix de victimes et au prix de
massacres etc
[Musique]
en fait très plaisir de
vous revoir c'est à chaque fois un
honneur et je sais tout le parcours que
vous avez que vous êtes engagés à partir
de 1947 je pense à 7 décembre kawase
début de décembre 47 points et moi
j'avais une question
sur le
1er décembre 1944 parce qu'on a déjà un
petit peu parlé de ça sur le moment
on tient relecquois sur le moment le
russe karoui karoui nous on était venu
en vacances on retournera et pris le
train à la gare de
dakar or en créant à l'école harribey
hathaway
où on voit le débit des militaires
qu'ils arrêtent de train le chef de gare
ou deep le trend le pop art qu il ya eu
une histoire aucun là bas
on te voit ce qu'on ne savait pas mais
tout d'un coup on a entendu des coups de
feu
tout le monde créé tout le monde qu'est
ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya
les militaires blanc là qui tient sur
les les les les revenants de la guerre
c'est comme ça qu'on a su qu'ils
tiraient sur l affaire
est ce que vous avez entendu les coups
de feu de la gare on attendait nettement
les coups de feu n'étaient
pas loin des regards la gare de tarascon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est la
guerre c'est après qu'on nous a expliqué
que ces soldats l'air une réclamé que le
but
les indemnités que leur devait pendant
la guerre
pour ne pas leur donner sens on les a
tuées
ce que nous allons nous en fait ici
ce n'est pas normal je m'excuse du terme
de vous le dire la france est ingrate
envers nous
combien de commun de dire que mes deux
d'anciens combattants sont morts dans
l'âme
quand tu quand tu vois
copains français ont compris tout ce qui
touche trois fois en quatre phases
plutôt que tu touches toi mais c'est pas
normal
c'est pas normal
des copains avec lequel tu as bull est
un peu partout tu la fermes du site et
le dialecte gp2 de séjour d'indochine
j'ai terminé après en algérie
pourquoi
martin
je ne dis pas ça coûte un peu pour vous
blâmez de la phrase n'a pas payé la
l'afrique
et pour nous les jeunes d'afrique est on
a aimé la france on a aimé la vrac on
s'est engagé dans l'armée parce que on
croyait que
l'histoire de rage là ça n'existait pas
dans l'armée au contraire
presque la majeure partie des officiers
étaient des racistes
comme une fois j'ai été cassé le
programme parce que jamais le
franc-parler de très bonnes
même c'était sûrement livré ses marques
je prierai mort du chanteur ne peut pas
faire un official heroes où l'officier
pas comment je viens de cette épaule à
je viens vous êtes beau
[Musique]
dans son si on pouvait avoir tant tout
comme jean-françois un peu mis le tirage
de sa
forme et sa balade avec un pièce et
c'est un crime des massacres commis par
la france à signer votre responsabilité
car il est en
jeu mais un haut responsable avait dit
domenech a dit mme shelley quoi assumer
votre responsabilité car nos
revendications mais votre responsabilité
faisabilité il buta voilà c'est ça
assumer vos responsabilités
il est un sport c'est un crime de masse
commis par la france assumez vos
responsabilités
il est temps
de commencer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc le 1er décembre au matin partir de
5h 6h ou à les assembler sur une
esplanade en particulier et c'est de là
qu'on va tirer sur ces hommes qui sont
désarmés
et à partir de là une des grandes
questions ou si c'est le nombre de
victimes a le bon là on arrive
arrive au coeur du mensonge d'état
nation on peut dire
moi j'ai eu un premier doute à la
lecture du rapport gagnant il est en
deux exemplaires qui disent deux choses
différentes à deux autorités
dans un rapport il a écrit que du côté
des mutins il ya 24 tués et 46 blessés
et transportés à l'hôpital de dakar et
dont 11 sont décédés par la suite donc
on a les onze décédée plus le 24 on
arrive à 35 dans l'autre rapport et nous
dit du côté des mutins 24 tués et 46
blessés et transportés à l'hôpital de
dakar est décédé par la suite
en 6 804 46 pouces 24 70
et là en fait pour moi c'était un des
éléments les us
plus à charge pour dire pourquoi tu dis
35 et pourquoi tu 66 et il le fait de
manière un peu voyeur et de la fédé 46
dont 46 des séparations c'est un peu
c'est subtil quoi on peut se dire que
voilà il me fait d'une manière
relativement habile et que c'est pas le
seul document c'est ça qui est important
aussi il ya plein de documents on se dit
mais c'est pas mal ça me dit ça rapport
aux deux rapports voit qu'ils ont à mon
point identique c'est-à-dire les ont
blessés par balle au niveau des services
d'hommes moi je me dis comment
comment sur un lieu où on dit qu'il ya
une rébellion kiev résistance entre deux
terres ailleurs normal noir comment
est-ce qu'on peut tuer tous les
résistants et consoles au niveau des
services d'ordre soit blessé donc moi je
vous dis que ça ça peut contredire le
fait que lyon a tout à fait t'as fait si
on sait si on pense que les tirailleurs
étaient armés il peut imaginer qu'ils se
seraient qui se seraient battus en fait
qu'ils n'allaient pas se situer comme ça
mais en plus ça c'est un blessé ont dit
un blessé par balle mais après ils vont
faire carrément une expertise une
expertise balistique et ils vous montrer
que le blessé par balle il a été blessé
par les gars du service d'ordre et que
c'est une balle qui a ricoché quelque
part et que ça lui est arrivé a déçu en
regardant les différents documents à
droite à gauche on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
une espèce de contradiction et
fondamentales qui nous laisse penser que
le massacre serait peut-être de l'ordre
de 300 à 400 tirailleurs donc c'est à
dire dix fois plus que 35 on va voir ce
document ici de la sûreté générale qui
nous parle d'une escale qui a eu lieu à
casablanca le bateau entre la bretagne
et dakar s'arrête à casablanca et là on
nous dit à ce moment 400 environ
refusèrent de partir et reste r à
casablanca
et
en fait l'officier qui a accompagné les
tirailleurs sur le bateau nous dit lors
de l'escale à casablanca aucun fait
n'est à signaler pendant les 24 heures
passées au qu'en 2009
ça pour moi ça passe en plus de l'aperçu
mais c'est vraiment l'élément décisif
qui nous dit bah vous mentez quoi soit
s'il y en a 400 qui descendent à
casablanca recchi ont pas remonter déjà
on comprend pas soit tout se passe bien
et dans ce cas là potentiellement plus
ils tirailleurs qui vont débarquer à
dakar le 21 novembre on a voulu
absolument diminuer le nombre de
tirailleurs présents au camp et si on
les a diminué c'est pour une raison très
simple c'est pour diminuer le nombre de
victimes
par rapport au nombre de victimes
comment tu peux enterré 400 corps
entre 9h
et 11h et midi je sais pas c'est énorme
404 sans cesse et
alors là c'est vraiment c'est la
question qui vient après celle du pillon
sait où vous serez les corps le fait
qu'on nous explique pas en fait que les
autorités militaires ne disent pas leur
supérieur qu'est ce qu'on va faire après
c'est aussi un élément qui nous fait
penser que voilà on est sur une
sorte de la dissimulation qui m'a
cherché à cacher à quelques niveaux que
ce soit en fait ça c'est pas facile de
répondre à cette question de est ce
qu'on n'a pas voulu écrire ces documents
est ce qu'on n'a pas voulu les
transmettre aux archives aux services
qui vont après les archives et
on les a écrits puis qu'à un moment on a
détruit ces documents qui nous donnerait
une liste de
tirailleurs débarqué à dakar une liste
de tirailleurs tué ensuite donc c'est
des gens qui avaient voilà qui avait
ramené qu'il y avait une identité un
visage et puis du jour au lendemain on
s'est pris ça devient des victimes
anonymes comme ça
comment
[Musique]
ah bon
à moi de revoir ça entre
[Musique]
nous avons moins notre mal dans le
silence à ces jeux trop longtemps - lui
trop longtemps nous avons noir notre mal
dans le silence assez
lassila ce même silence
le silence de cimetière de carole vous
avez cent seize parcelles bouche miettes
de thon fumé ceux qui ne sont pas de
ceux qui réclament leur sépulture
de ceux dont le corps sondés parmi
quelque part c'était rouge et le noir
citant trop neutre nous avons créé notre
mal dans le silence assez aujourd'hui de
les travaux de la réversion de joie
serait ce que les gens voulaient clameur
- des funérailles dignes de leur
sacrifice nous réclamons cette histoire
quelques mois ensemble et nous les
travaux de faire déclarer que l'a
reconnu soit de voir tout ça vous dit
nous réclamons de l'histoire de voir
toute sa vie nous réclamons de faire le
deuil de ses tirailleurs m'attaquez
l'organisation de leur dignité bafouée
et ceux de nos frères emprisonnés et
condamnés
merci ça
ça circule
cette conversation
la bombe
on n'est pas facile
ce
c'est
le personnage de mahmoud c'est vrai
qu'on n'en a pas parlé c'était un
tirailleur du service d'ordre tu vois
qui n'a pas été mobilisés kiné qui n'est
pas allé en europe il était là sur place
il a assisté il a vu ce qui s'est passé
il n'a rien pu faire et après il est
devenu gardien il est resté il a été
porté toute sa vie par cette culpabilité
là en fait de ne rien pouvoir faire
d'être là et il parle toute sa vie en
fait chaque nuit ce personnage chaque
nuit ils parlent au noir
c'est à dire qu'il est vieux toute sa
trajectoire c'est une descente et il
finit par rejoindre en fait il finit par
rejoindre l'espace dans lequel sont ces
hommes hors cub qui dans la pièce ne
sont ni mort en fait ni vivent ils sont
dans un espèce de haut de ça parce que
j'appelle le lot de ça dans un espace où
comme ils n'ont pas reçu de cette
culture il reste là en fait ils restent
là et lui il les rejoint petit à petit
tu vois le soulèvement poté exaspéré
l'eau
mais dix mois le soulèvement a exaspéré
l'aube où
le soulèvement petit les aspects l'eau
le soulèvement populaire a semé l'eau le
soulèvement à petit les aspects de l'eau
le sol air maroc at il exhorté le logo
le soulèvement péter l'exaspérer loeb le
soulèvement à petit les aspects le
le soulèvement petit les aspects
développe
le venez me faire revenir ce soir
revenez la
redonner ce soir devenez là les eaux sur
les autres rien la nuit à celle l'uefa
salle au port cette peau devant la leur
ce soir je ne suis plus conduire
seul
assis dans ce cimetière vider
les tomes sont vus de mes records sont
là
mais frères sur ses terres
mapou couvre feu encore
voilà qui passe d'un crime d'état à un
espace de crimes de papier si on peut
dire comment les autorités vont se
mettre à fabriquer des meneurs des
coupables est fabriqué des preuves pour
inculper ces tirailleurs et dire que
c'est eux qui en fait une commis les
actes qu'ils n'auraient pas dû commettre
on va arrêter 48 mineurs toujours voilà
entre guillemets dont 48 tirailleurs
mois désigné finalement ils vont juger
que 34 ça c'est un élément sur lequel on
n'a pas d'information qu'est ce qui se
passe entre 48 et 34 qu'est ce que
deviennent les 14 on sait pas
on a cette instruction qui durent
pendant un mois jusqu'au 29 décembre et
on a ce procès en fait à leur petit
façon la parole des tirailleurs ai
jamais entendu il ya même des choses
mais vraiment assez absurde il va
d'abord dire que les tirailleurs avait
des photos d'hitler avec eux
sauf qu'on n'a jamais démontré on va
dire qu'ils sont influencés par les
communistes soit ils sont pro allemand
soit ils sont pro communistes mais ils
peuvent pas être les deux à la fois quoi
en fait ces officiers en plus des des
tueurs en plus d'être des racistes ils
sont aussi les unes misogyne sont aussi
complètement misogyne et ils disent
finalement que ce sont ces marraine de
guerre avec qui les tirailleurs ou des
relations qu'ils oseront qui le remit
des mauvaises idées dans l'intérêt de
tous en tout cas qui leur ont fait
prendre conscience qu'ils avaient le
droit à réclamer de l'argent et
finalement c'est la faute de ces femmes
de sa femme blanche
et la justice militaire c'est vraiment
un délit de justice c'est vraiment de
toute façon le sort de ces tirailleurs
et jouer dès ce moment là parce que
début décembre met en marche cette
machination imagination juridique leur
sort et est pris on va dire
[Musique]
et
je vous
on
je ne reconnais pas les faits qui me
sont reprochés
[Musique]
je ne reconnais pas m'être retrouvé
parmi des tirailleurs armés
moi même je n'avais pas de couteau
[Musique]
jenny avoir dit il faut tuer tous les
blancs
[Musique]
la colonisation c'est rien d'autre que
des vols à main armée
c'est du vol l'impérialisme ce sont les
appels sont des voleurs sont des
braqueurs c'est petit événement dans la
banlieue de dakar est un révélateur
ce crime est annonciateur
d'une séquence qui sera quasiment annuel
quasiment annuelle 40 44
sétif et guelma 45 à 50 mille morts
hanoï et haïphong 46 ils vont à la
reconquête de l'indochine et pour barbe
madagascar 47
cent mille morts
dim cro bingerville korhogo
côte d'ivoire 48 parce que la rda est né
et que vos mains
le cameroun des 49 c'est parti le jour
où la vérité
sur carroll
apparaîtra au grand jour dans toute sa
nudité
comme jeudi ce sera radioactifs comme
déflagration mais non on compte pas sur
la bonne volonté de l'administration ou
de l'allier de la justice française on
compte sur le propre combat que les
africains doivent mener chez eux pour
eux-mêmes et pour ça
par exemple sur le nombre de victimes
nous
mon parti qui a un député à l'assemblée
nationale a écrit au premier ministre du
sénégal pour demander l'ouverture des
fosses communes l'exhumation des corps
si on ouvre les fosses communes
le nombre de crâne résiduelles que sont
identifiés parce qu'ils y accueille
trente paires corps
saura si on est dans l'ordre de la
dizaine dans l'ordre de la centaine
il y aura plus de débats si on me donne
les archives mais ces délices nominatif
donc tous les débats autour de charrues
sont en fin de compte des faux débats
puisque on a les moyens d'avoir la
vérité vraie
il suffit de la sortir au lieu de la
planquer
et puis d'assumer son histoire ce n'est
qu'une question de temps
parler des questions
par la formation par l'information
et par l'exemple
tôt ou tard
la vérité finira par prévaloir et à ce
moment là
la réconciliation sincère et définitive
devient possible
[Musique]
tu es toujours
oui
[Musique]
on y est
non
[Musique]
oman ça
non
[Musique]
quand
ces offres saison se sont battus pour
fon les pertes et ses ordres vers est
out et blanc que ge a payé ses ordres et
comme le coup dur avant d'enlever ces
offres ces tirailleurs relâchement
exterminer sans défense des armes au
service de l'armée française assassinée
mitrailler et jetés dans des fosses et
trois parfois cas par cas vous les avez
en mairie plus vous montez en disant
qu'ils se sont révélées ces antiques de
masse commis par la france
assumez vos responsabilités
il est temps c'est un crime de masse
tous mis par la france
assumez vos responsabilités
il est temps
[Musique]
voilà pour ce document signé marie
thomas pénet et françois-xavier des
stores c'est la fin de ce magazine merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau de
reporter sur france 2
[Musique]